you know on the on the plus side we are
giving historians and anthropologists of
the future a lot to do they're gonna
have it they're gonna be a very
interesting time of it as they as they
discuss and debate the question of when
exactly did the once great American
civilization of those ancient times go
insane and why did it happen and how and
I can only imagine thousand years from
now five hundred years from now what
conclusions they'll draw about that as
an American citizen myself in the
present day actually bearing witness to
the collapse of sanity and reason in
real time just as we all are I'm not
sure that I can answer those questions
and I I'm watching it happen
but perhaps hindsight will lend a little
bit of clarity for them what I do know
is that this case we've been talking
about this week the case of James
younger I think will be viewed as a in
the future as a seminal moment in our
collective plunge into madness it may be
seen as at least from a legal standpoint
the the point of no return
the crossing of some sort of Rubicon now
I want to talk a little more about this
case today because because if the mass
media isn't gonna cover it which they
are then that's all the more reason for
me to continue to talk about it in fact
in fact today I want to talk about both
of the of the stories that the mass
media has been ignoring this week and
I've covered both of them already but I
want to continue those conversations but
first just to review as we talked about
this James younger case if you didn't
catch the show yesterday just quick
quick review of what's going on a man
named Jeff younger has been locked in
this bitter court battle with his
ex-wife and George Ellis despite being a
medical profession professional herself
a pediatrician of all things got
helpless
she and presumably therefore someone who
understands basic facts about human
biology and child psychology George
Ellis got it into her apparently
deranged head that her son James is
really a girl named Luna and there's an
interesting fact about that name I'll
get to it in a little bit the factors
that convinced Georgia list that her son
Israeli her daughter include but are not
limited to her his affinity for the
movie frozen and his request to get a
girl toy from McDonald's she also says
that he started expressing an interest
in wearing girls clothing but Jeff
younger has explained in multiple
interviews that if James the son ever
had any desire or does have any desire
to wear a girl clothing sometimes it's
only because his mother started putting
him in dresses and painting his nails
and dressing him up like dressing him up
essentially like a drag queen when he
was 3 years old now Jeff also claims
that other methods of manipulation were
used so pretty insidious methods
according to him including he says for
example when the child was 3 years old
he would be locked in his room by his
mother in timeout and told that the
monsters only eat little boys Jeff also
speculates that Georgia 'lest would
withhold affection from the child unless
he was wearing girl clothes which is
another way of manipulating and getting
James to quote want to dress in girl
clothes so the court case revolved
around Jeff's efforts to rescue his sons
James and his twin brother there's
there's another boy involved in this
from the abuse of this sick and twisted
woman however the decision was passed
down yesterday as we talked about the
court ruled against the father virtually
all control of the child and all
decisions were handed over to the mother
Jeff brought this case trying to get
sole custody of the kids so that he
could prevent this transitioning into a
girl that is in the process of happening
right now so the jury looked at it and
they said yeah you know what we are
gonna give sole custody to somebody but
not you we're gonna give it to the mom
so that the kid can become a girl and
now she is free to continue the quote
social transition of James into a girl
process that is well underway already as
he goes by Luna and where's the girl
clothing and poses as a girl at school
and so on and eventually she can and
zooom ibly will start James on drugs to
chemically castrate him in fact she did
say in court that now she was very
careful not to say that yeah we're
definitely gonna do this right away
because she knows how that sounds
it sounds grotesque and barbaric which
it is but she did indicate that sure in
the future that is something that we
will explore that could happen in the
future and I would say it seems pretty
clear to me that if she has sole custody
the kid it's going to happen that's the
direction that this is headed
you start the social the social
transition means you're dressing them as
a girl you're pretending as a girl
you're calling them a girl you're in
other words is another word for
brainwashing conditioning you might
better call it social conditioning
rather than social transitioning and
then once you've done that the next step
in the process is you start doing the
drugs puberty blockers and then you give
them the hormone drugs the estrogen and
so on
all right um now it should be noted that
and this has been a point of contention
in the case that Jeff the father says
that when he is with the boy the boy
expresses no interest in being a girl
doesn't want to wear a girl clothing or
anything he refuses to wear girl clothes
that's that's what he says the mother
claims the opposite and says that no no
no when when Luna comes back to me
she quote-unquote is is relieved to
return to her quote-unquote identity as
a girl now I think both claims are
probably true in a sense the poor boy
realizes that it pleases his mother for
him to be Luna and so he wants to play
that role for her and in any case the
question of how he really identifies is
irrelevant the point is that James is a
boy plain and simple
whatever confusion he is suffering from
confusion that has been painstakingly
planted in his head by his mother his
mother who in my opinion should go to
prison just as every adult that is
involved in this kind of
thing including the doctors and
everybody else who is involved in this
sort of abuse of children should all go
to prison and they would in a sane world
but we don't live in a sane world but
that confusion could be easily
alleviated at most through counseling
and therapy you probably wouldn't even
need that when this child allegedly
first started claiming he was a girl at
3 years old which is when all this
started all you would have had to do is
say oh no no you're not a girl you're a
boy and you know something in a week
he'd be over it you know it's a in a
week he'd be past that phase if you
responded that way but if you are a
maniac and a three-year-old comes to you
and says I'm a girl and you go well well
oh my goodness he must be it she must be
a girl then says he's a girl it must be
a girl if you respond that way what a
coincidence
the child is going to persist in that
delusion and they're gonna become more
and more confused as time goes on now
the jury has decided as I said to give
Georgia list full custody we still don't
have a full verdict from the judge
though there are many related issues to
be ruled on and I believe that verdict
is gonna she's gonna that decision will
be made will be announced tomorrow there
still I think there still may be some
hope
hopefully the outcry from the sane and
rational and decent people of America an
outcry that has really been ramped up
this week thankfully maybe that will
have some effect maybe it will have some
influence and it might help the judge to
see the light on this issue I'm honestly
I'm not very hopeful about that I doubt
that that will be the result but we can
we can always pray and hope and continue
to raise awareness about this issue for
the next day before the final decision
is made what I did wonder I wanted to
answer a few objections I've heard from
people about how people like myself are
talking about this case there are three
main objections from what I can tell
the first is easy to deal with I've got
several emails saying that I'm giving a
one-sided version of the case when
actually the father is far from perfect
himself and what is then brought up are
court documents showing that one
the father was accused of lying about
his income and his work history to his
wife before they got married and two
that the father was accused of assault
now as for the first the father Jeff has
an explanation for what the wife and
says are lies he told before they got
married I don't know who's right who's
wrong or if it's something in the middle
usually with these things it is
regardless though who gives a damn none
of this has any bearing on the case
whatsoever and none of it makes him an
unfit father or justifies him losing
custody and certainly none of it means
that his son is really a girl and that's
the main point here now you might say
well it makes him unreliable so you
can't take his version of events at face
value my answer to that is we don't need
to you don't need to take anyone's
version of events at face value the
basic facts are not in dispute James is
a biological boy he is seven and for the
last several years at least his mother
has been claiming that he's a girl and
his mother now wants to transition him
into a girl that's not being disputed by
anybody everyone agrees on that and
that's all we need to know we don't need
to know anything else we do know a lot
more which only indicates the father in
my opinion but we don't really even need
to know any of that these basic facts
tell you basically everything you know
and then as for the the alleged assault
Jeff apparently was accused of
assaulting his wife in late 2017 this is
this is well after the marriage ended
and this is in the midst of all this
stuff with his wife trying to turn the
kid into a girl he was acquitted of the
assault so there's no reason to say
anything else about that but again that
accusation he was acquitted of it that
has no no bearing on this whatsoever
now then there's the third point
fenders of the mom in this case will
insist once they get back past trying to
discredit the father with with
accusations that are certainly far from
confirmed and I think have largely been
debunked but are all are also completely
irrelevant to this case defenders of the
mom will next go to saying well well
well no it's it's the mom is right you
know she's not forcing James to be a
girl because he really is a girl and we
know that he's really a girl because he
really does want to wear a girl clothes
and he really does want to identify as a
girl and so on now let me read a three
just to give you an example of this line
of argumentation I want to read a thread
to you from a guy named Barry Deutsch
on Twitter as he makes this case and
provides whatever evidence he can to
show that no the mother is actually
right and there is as he puts it there's
a panic on the write about this and the
panic is completely off-base so let me
give you this is this is this is the
attempt to vindicate the mother okay it
says the thread on the save
james-younger panic on the right they're
claiming that James younger as they
insist on calling Luna wants to be a boy
and her evil mother is forcing her to
identify as a girl and where a girl
clothing that's not what a CPS
investigation found when I'm posting
here are screen shots of the CPS
investigators testimony at trial with no
parent present Lunas says she's a girl
and denies that anyone's making her be a
girl she also said she's afraid of her
dad because he won't let her wear a girl
clothes
that's why quote/unquote she is afraid
not because there's any abuse or
anything going on but according to this
claim it's because the boy wants to wear
girl clothes and the dad won't let
continues the CPS investigator also
interviewed Lunas teacher Lunas teacher
confirm what Luna says Luna identifies
as a girl and the teacher doesn't
believe any one's pressuring Luna to do
that the CPS investigator also
interviewed Lunas twin brother Luke
actually the between twins by the name
is Jude not Luke Jude confirms Lunas
story Luna has always identified as a
girl
their dad forces Luna to dress as a boy
which makes Lunas sad and short the CPS
investigator found absolutely no
evidence that Lunas mom is forcing Luna
to wear girl clothes or to use the name
Luna but the CPS and we'll get to that
name thing in a second as I said because
it's very it's actually there's there's
something very there's a very important
detail about this name that I'm going to
get to the CPS investigator found
evidence Lunas dad is forcing her to
wear boy clothes you can read the
transcript okay that's that's basically
it so there's there are all the facts
laid out that are supposed to vindicate
the mother this is the best anyone can
do essentially the argument is that what
the mother is doing is not abuse and the
jury's decision is not wrong and all of
this is perfectly fine because the boy
actually is a girl do you see how insane
this is I hope you do he's not a girl
he's just simply not factually
objectively scientifically he is not a
girl
so to dress him like one to claim he is
one to have him live as one to
facilitate his transition into one he's
crazy
is abusive is deranged
is evil I don't give a damn whether the
seven-year-old boy really says he wants
to wear dresses or not it's clear from
court documents and from all reports
that he sometimes says he wants to and
sometimes says he doesn't he's confused
why is he confused because he's a child
and because his mother has been claiming
he's a girl since he was three of course
he's confused of course he's gonna say
he wants to wear dresses and so on all
of that is irrelevant
he's a child who doesn't know what's
going on and as I will point out for the
forty millionth time he doesn't know
what a girl
he literally doesn't know what he's
saying he can't possibly identify as a
girl because he doesn't know what that
is you can't identify as something when
you don't know what it is this all
started when he was three years old
again that's not under dispute you heard
from the from the brother saying oh he's
always identified as a girl well from
what the brother what the brother means
is this as for as long as I can remember
this has been going on which makes sense
because generally you start forming
memories when you're three years old
this goes back to when he was three and
the mother says ah we first started
saying it was a girl when he was three
three three years old you lunatic
three years old do you know what a three
year old knows about being a girl
nothing nothing
not a single thing nothing now even if a
three year old did know something about
being a girl the biological reality
would still remain so that even if a
child that young did actually have a
substantive understanding of biological
sex so as to make this choice it still
wouldn't matter because you can't choose
your sex it's impossible but this is
doubly insane because a child at three
years old has no clue what that means I
have a three-year-old okay and I've had
two other three-year-olds who are now
six it's just if you've ever spent any
time around a three-year-olds
particularly if you've ever been a
parent of a three-year-old you know this
these thing kids kids don't know
anything so a three-year-old says I'm a
girl all you have to follow up with is
what's that what do you mean hey they
don't mean anything at most what they
mean is I like I like pretty pink things
great no problem
three-year-olds can like pretty pink
pink things nothing wrong with that the
suggestion that that actually means that
this boy at three years old is a girl
and it's somehow mystically recognized
this inner truth of this girl that is
magically trapped inside the shell of
their boy body this you have you have
educated people who think this way now I
mentioned the thing about the name
here's an interesting tidbit from the
Texan and then they this a publication
down in Texas where this is happening
they've been on top of this case a lot
of great information when James first
started identifying as a girl do you
know what name he wanted for himself he
goes by Luna now according to mom but it
wasn't it wasn't Luna originally you
know what it was
the name was Starfire
that's the name he wanted I actually
think this is this is I think this is
maybe one of the most important facts
that came out in this case he wanted to
be called Starfire and any parents of
children might know that Starfire is a
cartoon character from the show teens
Titans Teen Titans go my kids don't
watch that show Saturday okay he wanted
his name to be Starfire cartoon
character from a cartoon show what does
that tell you it tells you that
James was literally identifying as a
cartoon character because he's a child
you know my sons have identified as many
fictional characters where they really
in some sense in some way believe that
they are that character my I know it's a
you hear this as a classic response to
all this madness when someone said oh my
my son identifies as a dinosaur I guess
I guess he's Regulus I shouldn't send
him to Jurassic Park and that might be
it might be a cliched response at this
point but it's it's a cliché for a
reason it's true
my son my three-year-old son also thinks
that he's and he thinks that he's Rexy
t-rex now what does that mean well let's
really think about this for a second
when my three year old son goes around
saying he's a t-rex is he joking no he's
not joking three or three-year-olds
don't know how to joke that
three-year-olds have no concept of humor
they don't they don't tell jokes dad to
have a concept of humor you need a
concept of irony in these things and
three-year-olds are not sophisticated
enough for that so he's not joking is he
lying he's not lying
three olds can't lie either
three-year-olds are incapable of telling
a real lie now they might say things
that aren't true but they're not capable
of lying because they don't understand
the difference between truth and
falsehood between reality and fantasy so
when my three-year-old says that he's a
t-rex he really does think at some level
he really believes that he's a t-rex now
if my three-year-old were 30 years old
and saying that and believing it then
it'd be a sign that he's mentally ill no
matter what age he is it could never be
a sign that he is really a t-rex trapped
inside a human body we can be pretty
confident of that if he was older then
we would say now we've got a mental
disorder on our hands of some kind let's
get him some counseling but at three
years old it's it it it's just
it's funny maybe you play along with it
a little bit you have fun you play
dinosaurs I'll chase my son around the
house he plays the dinosaur he's chasing
me I'm chasing him because he's three so
when you've got a human being with the
kind of psychology where they can really
be convinced at some level that they are
a dinosaur or a superhero or a dog or a
lion or a dragon or anything and my kids
have been all of those things sometimes
in the same day when you've got a person
with that kind of psychology as a child
how could you possibly take them
seriously when they say that they're the
opposite gender it's the exact same kind
of thing they're not identifying some
internal truth it's just a fantasy it's
it's a it's it's just a kid being a kid
and not understanding what is real and
what isn't kids again literally do not
know the difference between reality and
fiction there are a lot of adults these
days I don't know what either but they
don't have an excuse a kid at three
years old doesn't know so when a
three-year-old thinks that spider-man is
really out there not just out there but
when they when a three-year-old watches
TV and sees a cartoon they really think
that that cartoon is real now how could
they possibly think that it's a cartoon
in a little bottle what do you what do
they think well I don't know I'm not
even sure I because I can't remember
being three years old enough to
understand what they're really thinking
in their head but they do think you know
if you ask a three-year-old does Bugs
Bunny exist is Bugs Bunny real they're
gonna say yes and if you then if you
really wanted to be a jerk and spoil
their their fantasy and you said no
bucks bunny isn't really fake well you
couldn't spoil the fantasy because that
wouldn't mean anything to them
they would say what is what what does
that mean the concept of something not
being real means nothing to a child at
that age which is why they are not
empowered to make important decisions
for themselves it's why in fact they're
not really empowered to make any
decisions for themselves
and it's why their declarations about
their own self-identity are meaningless
completely meaningless except as a fun
little game that maybe you play along
with and if it gets too out of hand and
they start taking it too seriously then
maybe you stop playing along with it
well one last by actually one last point
about this quickly that on this name
thing so the kid wanted to be star fired
the mom said now let's pick something
else and they settled on Luna it's
interesting that all of these painfully
progressive parents who let their kids
choose their own gender
none of them let the kid choose their
own name and I know that's the case
because they always settle on some
trendy gender-neutral name you think the
kid came up with that you think the kid
came up with Luna or jazz or sky you
think you think you what do you think
the kid went on Google to look up know
if you say to a three-year-old pick any
name you want they're gonna end up with
star fire or t-rex or Spider Man or
Wonder Woman or something like that
so that's how you know you know you got
these trans these court transgender kids
running around
none of them are named Wonder Woman none
of them are legally named Wonder Woman
why is that because the parents choose
the name why do the parents choose the
name because the parents know even
though a name really is a social
construct really is a cultural thing
really is arbitrary really can be
anything you wanted to be they choose
the name because the parents realize
that a name is an import
decision that a kid is not mature enough
to make and that a kid will think that a
certain name is cool when he's three but
won't think it's cool anymore when he's
thirty so they don't want to curse the
kid with a name when he's thirty that he
chose when he was three hmm yes
now take that logic and apply it to
gender and maybe now you start to
understand all right so on Monday I told
you about the case of Democratic
congresswoman Katie Hill a report in red
state said that Hill allegedly had a
sexual relationship with a 22 year old
female staffer and also an affair with
another member of her staff though this
one was a man the media showed no
interest in this case whatsoever
because because she's a woman mainly and
as I as I have pointed out the fact that
she's a Democrat obviously helps her and
if she was a Republican probably they'd
be more likely to report on it I mean
they'd certainly be more likely to
report on it of course but the main
thing that gets her off the hook for
this is that she's a woman and women
when it comes to sexual indiscretions
are just not held to the same standard
and accusations against women of
sexually inappropriate behavior just are
not taken seriously by almost anybody
because there seems to be this general
attitude of well of a woman does it it's
not as bad nobody will come out and say
that but I gave the example when you
have for example all these teachers
female teachers who are having sex with
13-year old boys in their class the
attitude of almost everybody seems to be
that's not quite as bad because it's a
woman no again nobody will say it no one
will say that but that's apparently how
almost everyone feels about it because
that's why there's very little outrage
about these cases and usually what
anyone does is just they just they just
crack jokes about it in fact the often
times the media if the media does report
and the media will report on the cases
of teachers and students because that's
salacious and it gets clicked so they
can't help but report on it but when
they do very often what they'll call it
in the headline they'll say something
like with this exact
phrase it'll be teacher-teacher caught
in sex romp with 13-year old student
that phrase sex romp that exact phrase
has often been used in headlines by the
media to describe the sexual abuse of
adult females or by adult females of
male children you're never gonna see the
phrase sex romp used to describe abuse
when the genders are flipped anyway in
this case there are all kinds of now
there's no minors involved okay there
are all kinds of ethical and potentially
legal issues here related to her having
sex with with with people who are on her
payroll paying her sex partners with
campaign funds and all of the ethical
issues wrapped up in a person in a
position of power a person in Congress
getting sexually involved with a young
staffer just out of college there are
also pictures that are floating around
out there one picture is Katie Hill
appears to be Katie Hill
nude and brushing the hair of what
appears to be her young staffer although
the the face is blurred out of the
staffer
now we all know if that was a picture of
a male congressman naked and brushing
the hair of some 22 year old staffer
that would be headline news everywhere
huge controversy they would be holding a
press conference they would have already
resigned by now in disgrace
Katie Hill does it and that nobody cares
media doesn't talk about it
there's more more information though now
the Daily wire has a report now you go
to daily wire.com and see this more
information and this is coming again
from red state and red state has been on
top of this and one thing about that
also so the site red state conservative
website they've been on top of this
story and that fact has been used to
discredit the story people saying well
it's it's conservative but just a
conservative rag propaganda reporting on
this no one else is talking about it
I've also heard a similar thing with the
James Young store
where some liberals say oh it's only
been conservative sites talking with it
that's because the liberal sites refused
to talk about it and with something like
this Katy Hill case she's a
congresswoman in California there are
pictures and text messages that somebody
had and was releasing to the media do
you do you really think that red state
that the person who had this information
about Katie Hill you think a red state
is the first place that person went
there is no way the first the first
people in media to hear about this would
have been the local media in California
they would have been the first people to
catch wind of it and so the fact that
red state is publishing it means that
they passed on it and it means it must
mean that all of the major mass media
left-wing outlets passed on it because
it's just impossible to believe that red
state would be the first ones to get
this information to get this bombshell
about Katie hill anyway but red state
they've been doing a good job reporting
on it and the daily wire well let me let
me quote the daily wire now as they are
talking about the red state report so as
the young female can't campaign staffer
who described the relationship as being
toxic reported reportedly wrote hill a
message in 2019 June 2019 saying in part
I am terrified of pushing back against
you or upsetting you I've seen how you
treat Kenny and I think that if I cause
any issues even if I am worried about
how you were acting that very quickly
you will decide you don't want me in
your life
in a message to has let this staffer
repeat reportedly said I don't know I
was getting ready and I was thinking
about how much Katie liked to watch me
then reference to a hobby
watch me do some kind of hobby I don't
know it's okay she can't take this from
me she can ruin politics take all my
friends and isolate me but she can't
have this then red state added the
staffer continued her work on the
campaign despite the awkwardness and
emotional distress it caused Hill
however seemed tone-deaf
asking her former lover to apply
sunscreen on her prior to an event in
front of the rest of the staff
the young woman later texted hill to
express her displeasure what's the point
here the point here is that what we're
what we have been told by the left what
we've been told by the me2 movement for
years now is that relation sexual
relationships even if they are
quote-unquote consensual you know
they're ostensibly supposedly on the
surface anyway
consensual relationships between a
person in a position of power to a
person who is a subordinate and and in
this case a very a very junior
subordinate you've got a congresswoman
to a staffer just out of college that
those relationships according to the
meanto movement and according to what
the left has been saying up until this
moment with Katie Hill those
relationships cannot really be
consensual because of the power dynamic
because of the disparity because the
other person in the relationship is
going to feel potentially threatened
they're gonna feel like they can get out
of it if they want to they're gonna feel
like they can't be themselves it can
express themselves that they have to
just go along with whatever this other
person wants because of the power they
have over them they're gonna feel
threatened they're gonna feel
intimidated and what do you know you see
these text messages allegedly from this
person expressing just that feeling that
yes I I'm intimidated I can't and what
do you know you have Katie Hill it would
seem potentially taking advantage of
that discomfort or at least now as as
the red state says she was tone deaf I
think that's a generous interpretation
where you've got the staffer expressing
discomfort and everything intimidation
and then Katie Hill after they'd
broken-up goes to the staffer and says
put some some sunscreen on me in front
of everybody
now you can interpret that as her being
tone deaf
I personally my perspective I interpret
that as malicious and a Power Move
because there's just no way you've got
you've got this history with this person
you're looking for someone to apply
sunscreen to you and you choose her of
all people that's no that's not tough in
my opinion that's not tone-deaf that's
not a coincidence that's you're doing
that on purpose that's manipulation and
that is certainly how it would be
interpreted if this was a man we're
talking about so even if the media wants
to ignore this this is still a huge
story it is still a scandal it does
matter
Katie he'll finally after days came out
with a statement addressing some of this
now the fact that she was able to get
away with saying nothing about it for
several days just shows you again how
she's not being held accountable how the
media is running cover for her but she
came out and predictably there was no
apology nothing she made herself the
victim she said she was the victim
because all this information was coming
out about her and so it's really all
about her she's the victim and she'll
get away with that that's that's it she
could come out she's the victim and move
on that is what we call female privilege
okay let's go to emails Matt Walsh oh oh
actually before emails this doesn't
require really any Compton I just wanted
to play this if you haven't seen this
clip we got to play it because as you
know and the NBA NBA players many of
them LeBron James and among them but not
the only one have been embarrassing
themselves by falling to their knees and
licking the boots of the Chinese
government as we have seen of the last
few weeks finally we've got someone not
a current NBA player but someone
associated with the NBA someone who
works in professional basketball as a
commentator now Shaquille O'Neal I knew
we could count on him to have the right
take on this and he shared his take on
the China thing
and he he for one at least was not doing
any bootlicking listen to this
he has American people we do a lot of
business in China and they know and
understand our values and we understand
that values and one of our best values
here in America is free speech we're
allowed to say what we want to say and
we're allowed to speak up about
injustice and that's just how it goes
and if people don't understand that
that's something that they have to deal
with but you know I just started with
unfortunate for you know both parties
and then you got people speaking when
they don't know what they're talking
about but no Daryl Morey was right
whenever you see something wrong going
on anywhere in the world you should have
the right to say that's not right and
that's what he did and but but again you
know when it comes to business sometimes
you have to tiptoe around things but
again they understand our values we
understand our values in here we have
the right to speak specially with the
social media we're gonna say whatever we
want to say when we want to say it there
you go Shaq see Shaq is a legend for a
reason that was a great the fact that
he's the first one associated with the
NBA to say that and the fact that it
actually required courage on his part to
say it all he did was come out in favor
of free speech and stipulate that we are
not a communist regime and we have free
speech and we could say what we want the
fact that it took courage and it did
take courage for him to say that is just
just tells you how sad it's gotten in
the NBA but good for him okay do we have
time for emails I guess we'll do maybe
one Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
wall show at gmail.com talk about pit
bulls in the email portion you know so I
got a lot of pit bull related email I
haven't got a chance to go through a lot
of it this way this isn't
but from rich says dear Matt I agree
with your take on airplane slash bus
seating arrangements if you're sitting
next to someone but the opportunity to
move and give both of you more space
arises you should take it here's an
interesting wrinkle though what about at
a bar what if you're sitting at a
crowded bar by yourself and all the
other seats are taken but people start
leaving except the guy next to you
doesn't leave so now you two are sitting
next to each other at a mostly empty bar
do you move in that situation or would
it be insulting now I like this first of
all of all the emails dealing with
serious issues making interesting points
this is the one I decide to answer
but-but-but-but because actually I was I
was in this exact situation recently and
you know when you're an antisocial
person like I am there's a lot of
there's a lot of calculus that goes into
things you're constantly working out
equations and figuring out and mostly
you're figuring out how can I just avoid
being around people in any in any given
situation
so this presented now this is it this
isn't it as we have talked about you're
sitting next to someone on a plane the
airplane ends up being half full the
doors shut you know no one else is
coming and you have a chance to move and
give them more space move all the way to
another aisle if you can so you both get
it you know to another row if you can to
get a whole road to yourself then you
should do that
rich brings up an interesting wrinkle
that so I was in the similar situation I
was at the bar I was at the bar recently
watching Ravens game bar was full so
we're all packed in like sardines around
halftime though there was a mass exodus
for some reason people started leaving
even though it was a good game about ten
of the people that were at the bar left
so now it's mostly empty just like you
said rich except the guy next to me did
not leave he's still there so now we're
in that exact spot where we're sitting
at a mostly empty bar but the two of us
are sitting right next to each other and
I'm thinking that something and okay do
I move and this is a little bit more
difficult because yes that we should
give ourselves more space but then in
that situation at the bar if I move
doesn't make it does it look is it too
conspicuous
does it look like I'm making somewhat of
a statement against him like I want to
be around him and I didn't want to come
off that way because he was a nice guy
it's just I enjoy my personal space and
so I was I was turning this over in my
head I was deliberating about it and as
I was thinking about it the guy got up
and just moved across the bar and the
funny thing is that even though I was
probably just about to do the same thing
I was slightly offended I would I
slightly in my head I thought well
what's that guy's problem what you got a
problem with me
so to answer your question I guess yes
it is slightly offensive to move in that
case but you should do it anyway the
guiding principle is this anytime you
have an opportunity to be antisocial you
should take it at least that's how I
operate I can't promise it's a key to
success and happiness in life but anyway
that's one way to live at least and we
will leave it there thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wired production
copyright the Lee Weyer 2019 if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there